the gyro can experience a 2010 was
really somewhere around the time Vegas
started becoming these these electronic
music shows started taking precedent
they're the biggest [ __ ] thing I was
staying at the Wynn recently and the
hotel room we were at was overlooking
the pool and I forget who it was that
was playing there but it was [ __ ] K
yeah yeah and like you don't and
especially when you're a you know we're
like above like high above looking down
the room first I view it was so crazy
was so loud and so crazy and there was
everybody this never existed
yeah I mean it's true Vegas for a long
time yeah this is a new thing it is a
new thing over the last nine years
exactly and it's overtaking Vegas
everywhere you go there's these gigantic
billboards with you there your face on
it or whatever other DJs in right place
and who's the guy with the [ __ ]
marshmallow head there's a guy at
marshmallow yeah well I hit that's
marshmallow yeah you know Kay that's
like the unknown comic a marshmallow on
his head but there's so many I didn't
even know who that was like my kids are
explained to me my 11 year always
explained to me marshmallow [ __ ] do you
know who Mark and and we're there and
it's just it's everyone that's going out
in Vegas but it used to be Vegas used to
be like a cultural weird void yeah right
you would have some big acts that would
come through there but it always seemed
like they were at the end of the run
right yeah yeah yeah you had to be at
the end of your run yeah like when
Michael Jackson was considering during
Vegas he's like okay he's like finally
saying that this is the right or you
know it's like you see how it did like
Celine Dion you know did a residency in
Vegas like she's probably just tired
Donnie Marie yeah you know metal oh yeah
Barry Manilow you know like carrot top
does the residency there's I mean he's
doing really well it's not it's not a
knock yeah I know it's not it's really
not but it's that's what it was but then
all of a sudden it became electronic
music and it's like
Wow what is happening like the you know
these things are enormous like there's
so much bigger than any other kind of
event that you have in Vegas other than
like massive sporting events like ricey
or something yeah well it definitely
it's it's provoked by energy too you
know like and it's that's infectious yes
yeah it's a [ __ ] great time yeah if
you go to see Barry Manilow or you know
whenever who there's no knock on them
but you know I'm saying it's like I'm
sure it's fun it's mellow it's like
whatever you're into but when you're
seated you know like you're seated for a
reason because you're there to like sit
and just enjoy yes at there's no seats
at a steve aoki show I mean there are
they're like the tables and stuff but no
one's sitting down right it that's the
that they'll be strange to see so much
unless service past trunk or something
but for the most part everyone's
standing and jumping and being part of
the moment and that's that's my job
yeah I need to make sure everyone's
attention is on me and then I'm taking
them to this next level I've always
wondered what it's like to live in Vegas
though like I've never lived there you
know my good friend Dana White lives
there he loves there she raves about it
but I've always liked like Vegas okay so
for me so I'm LA guy right like my heart
and like you know I love Los Angeles
I know LA so well and you know with LA
you have your limitations it's Los
Angeles you can't like if you want to
build your dream house you can't have a
lot of money to do that in Vegas when I
moved there in 2013
I got a sick deal I bought my house
16,000 square feet whoa 2.8 million I
think - hilarious
yeah 2.8 it was a short sale as a total
steal I mean like the guts were not good
like it was like one of those like prop
homes almost so I had a Regan like I
spent like five million into the house
and it was more about building my own
dream house as I would want to have it I
have a foam pit in there with a
trampoline room I have I the pool in my
backyard was too far away from my house
so I filled it in and I built a pool at
16 feet deep right next to my patio
that's 20 feet up I built the patio out
so that way I can jump into the pool
from from the top now I'm like Kidd and
basically a big kid
and I just think about how I want to
make my house fun interactive for the
artists that come there for me I have a
fun gym I've you know I got my own like
chess station backgammon station have a
poker room you know it's it's the most
hospitable house you know and I have all
this space I have like a big shoe room a
big shoe collector I got a crazy library
with books and records you know I have a
Bruce Lee mirror room a mirror room it's
my closet but it's just like you walk in
it's like LED strips everywhere with
mirrors and you know I'm just having fun
I'm having fun with my house there's a
mirror room I have some really crazy
really beautiful art but I got this
amazing Banksy piece and so I you know
been starting to collect art there's my
shoe room and dozen banks you get mad if
people buy a [ __ ] I well I bought it
from him oh you met him tell us what he
looks like he is a he's a girl oh just
kidding I never met her but uh with I
you know I got into through his some
people to get into is he definitely a
real person you know I don't know how
yeah it's someone in 2019 it's managed
to stay that secretive yeah he kind of
amazing credible because he's a cultural
phenomena yeah I mean he's I mean
everybody knows who banks he is yeah
right or you know of the oxy I should
say but no one knows who he is which is
crazy who the [ __ ] has ever pulled that
off right what a unique human being yeah
it's true how does that work how do I
it's not sure I think yet I mean it's
it's like his he's always seeming to
find a way to troll people in a social
or political critique just like he did
with the the art sale of the shredded
paint yes how amazing was that yeah that
was pretty crazy yeah but watch those
people after they paid it and
see the the thing me dropped it all red
though but let me ask you this though I
don't want to go too deep into this but
because I don't know if I'm like
stepping anyone's toes here but if this
is really suffrages or you know what
like a real auction house I'm thinking
look at the painting or the piece are
they going to open up the frame and make
sure there's not some weird drill going
through like I think they would ever
expect that to be the case
I mean but your but your and your
antique you should be checking
everything making sure everything's
identical well if it's an authentic
piece and they somehow or another some
reliable source brings it to them as an
authentic piece they just accept the
fact they don't check the details of the
piece I mean what can they do
meanwhile by the way I'll take that and
[ __ ] glue that [ __ ] back together
believe it that well you want to like
that that's so play it's like what makes
the value is it right let it actually
have it hanging there that's why you
want it in your house really you want it
just like that yeah look at the people's
face sometimes I forget the phone oh no
oh no Thurston we've lost the piece yeah
you know I I wish like it's funny that
we talked about this because sometimes I
forget like you know we're having a chat
and I realized oh there's a lot of
people listening in on this so maybe I
should give away some of the stuff that
I've learned about it but yeah anyways
we'll leave it there well he's
definitely unique human
[Applause]